I feel really sick I'm hearing voice
bring me back my creatures
could be whatever we want
you should be extremely afraid
or fit
what's up everybody we have a brand new
venom TV spot trailer but before we get
started congrats to youtube user G
Ramirez underscore 3 2 3 4 being the
next winner of the Avengers infinity war
blu-ray giveaway for the rest of you do
not worry the giveaway still continues I
will be picking one more winner from
social media so be sure to follow me on
there and one more final winner on
YouTube for a very special final
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts on
the video and your favorite superhero as
you can see there aren't many new scenes
in the trailer but there is one
particular scene that is worth talking
about this isn't too different for what
they did with Avengers infinity war and
what they did with ant-man and the wasp
putting mini TV spot trailers out there
but having just slightly different
scenes in each one of them and for this
venom TV spot it's a scene with dr.
Carlton Drake it's an interesting scene
because we hear him say bring me back my
creature it appears that this is when
Eddie Brock escapes with the Venom
symbiote there are many screens in the
background it seems like they're
monitoring him but what's really
interesting is the way that dr. Carlton
Drake views the symbiotes so he says my
creature so he clearly looks at the
symbiotes as his own creatures we
already know that there will be multiple
symbiotes
in the movie including riot and scream
we don't know too much about them yet
but if they are dr. Drake's creatures
then he may use them to fight venom this
is obviously a different direction that
they're going with the symbiotes than
they do in the comics so let me know
your thoughts about this new trailer in
the comments below and again the
infinity war blu-ray giveaway still
continues all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts in
the video and your favorite superhero
you can also increase your chances of
winning by following me on social media
thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]